okay here we go welcome to this video
smoke and mirrors I hope he's not
putting up smoking mirrors in that game
mg3 or 93 mi museum yeah that's a bit of
the thing is I don't like it if they get
any five so I go d for but that is
rather dull if you take some place
Knight d2 before but that's one of the
that's a soft spot in my in my
repertoire at life I would have thought
that seat XD for it's almost automatic
you not what is he doing e six okay well
okay that cannot be terribly bad but the
surprising there should be seven maybe
that leads to some unpopular version of
the semi taraji know it takes or that it
should be nice for what
very nice catalan bishop that I have
there on g2
it's difficult I mean how is he
developing cannot move that Bishop down
check check but that looks absolutely
unplayable 9 p-5 is a big thread already
and a six-night a4s is also Wow so just
falling apart
so and after this night be five
let's let's think about this for a
moment if that's really the best way not
be five I have that move anyway I think
this is maybe even better so that after
move liking to e7 I have night to a form
yes and now plot probably just rocks you
wanna so
and yeah so spoiled for choice
can hardly move the question is I'm if I
can can I do something can do something
powerful here that the twins quickly I
this is the only way I have a good moves
like 94 that same let's do that nothing
fancy but it is just good the idea is to
invade on the seventh with Roxy seven
we hope to measure page five check now
but Roxy seven is just is just stronger
threatening bishop h5 with me to come
Wow
so I wouldn't be surprised if they're
the engine and see some kind of made in
X but how do you do it as a human that
still has to be done
I don't see you better than this but
this very likely is the very likely
there is one but it's it's that's just
good so why not I'm threatening Luke to
d7d to d7 and you cannot move the edge
rock as a seven-day sir this is the
liability some doubling maybe first put
this to e5 and then doubling on the 7th
thread is before now with the bishop
having no square
hmm Jim
so really remarkable I don't see don't
see a maid or anything super decisive
from probably just too bad to blind but
ok just one point in the chess game to
win
is he has no move Bishop d6 I can just
take than Luke c8 and at the end of
could have any component game I've won
that b7 part after all
yeah probably that's the clock run down
wasn't the most pleasant experience ever
that game black forfeits on time okay so
let's let's check what went wrong here
for black yeah here on the best line for
black is just to take and go here
attacking this and why it doesn't really
have anything better than this check and
here this is probably equal like has to
be a bit precise but it's not a big deal
he will probably draw this with good
play yeah I think white is has good
chances for a slight advantage but the
way he played it I think it got almost
unbearable this is already very
difficult yes no good move now I cannot
move that Bishop due to my queen being
so powerful and deform and yeah we saw
what Chatwood happened here check I just
just really really bad so here be sure
before i think is good a six rook see
one ya the engine approves and so and
here the question is if I can do
something better in this position yeah
the engine wants to play Bishop c7 King
is seven Jack and back and know what
exactly this I don't know I did but then
then I like my movements I mean it's
just good for white and probably good
enough it just shows how powerful those
bishops are really has no moves at five
age six ok I could have I could have one
with that shaky already
um ah yeah you know what I did jesse is
that this is a major mate quite cute
meet actually okay yeah then then Bishop
h5 was better but okay it's just a
matter of picking picking up the pieces
it's just it's just too bad dad here he
let the clock run down yeah this some
the opening here that that was just too
bad like was losing far too much time if
we look at this I'm already cancelled
after Bishop on that strong diagonal and
he's still kind of in his tracks and his
bishops have not moved and cannot move
and he can simply not match the power of
that Catalan bishop on g2 okay well
thanks for watching